at least you're out in the world you
must meet a lot of girls Barry is that
why you left the Beehive to meet lady
bees because I hate to break it to you
but you already have those are pollen
jocks Wow
what do you think buzzy boy I'm talking
about those ones right there I'm talking
about those ones worker bees that go out
and gather pollen what you know as the
pollen jocks yeah they're all female
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
the show that's about to give BuzzFeed a
run for its money duh hey it all makes
sense to me now
after staring at this stupid movie for
way too long something just clicked as
I'm writing this script you notice
everyone's hair cut in this movie the
women all have beehive hairstyles
obvious joke is obvious but the guys
they'll have buzz cuts buzz cuts and
here you'll think that my jokes are bad
this is a real movie that ran in real
movie theaters gentlemen this I'm sure
by now you're all familiar with the
memes coming out of the B movie but in
case you've never actually stopped to
watch the movie or you did watch it but
need a refresher because the plot wasn't
exactly the most memorable thing about
it well then here's what you need to
know
Barry B Benson is a honeybee who travels
outside of the hive falls in love with a
human woman named Vanessa and eventually
uncovers a shocking conspiracy the bees
are being enslaved by humans to produce
honey what bees don't know about this
this is stealing a lot of stealing so
Barry decides to sue the entire honey
industry and wins as you can imagine
this has some unintended consequences
now that humans are no longer eating
honey the pollen jocks that harvest
nectar for the hive no longer have to
work and that causes the world's plants
to start wilting so it's up to Barry
information as a human girlfriend Oh to
find the last remaining flowers in
America and pollinate plant life on
earth before it's too late
oh and a bunch of bees team up to save a
commercial jetliner from crashing oh
yeah there's also that moment or Vanessa
dies in a gruesome parasailing accident
so many things are wrong about this film
the fact that bees and humans can
apparently talk to each other yet
berries the first bee ever to try
striking up a conversation with anyone
like just the fact that berry has a
romantic rival and that romantic rival
is a human but besides that the fact
that Ken his romantic rival has a bee
allergy that the movie just treats like
a joke even though B allergies are very
real and very serious medical problems
I mean seriously you think that people
are spending hundreds of dollars on
EpiPens just for the lulz and yet ken is
the one who's treated like the villain
because he doesn't want to be in a room
with the bee who could potentially kill
him and all of this wrapped in a movie
about a love affair between an insect
and a human nee Jerry Seinfeld and a
human perhaps worst of all is the
message of the film that bees are a
vital part of the ecosystem and without
them plant life as we know it would be
wiped out because this simply isn't true
in fact it's the complete opposite from
us and the environment as a whole would
be better off if Barry B Benson and his
brash buddies would just buzz off
Sherman Isley yeah I know we're all
trained to love bees at this point but
get ready because today I'm gonna prove
how everyone especially the B movie is
right now what concern on this episode
was something I said a few weeks ago in
the tide pot episode honeybee
populations are on the rise for like the
first time ever and I shared that as a
positive news story but after I finished
that episode it got me researching we
hear all the time that honeybee
populations are on the decline and that
this is a terrible thing for the
ecosystem but is it really I was
honestly surprised by what I found first
honey bees aren't actually native to
North America they're an invasive
species that was first introduced back
in 1622 when European settlers brought
him over the Native Americans even
called them the white man's fly let's be
clear they weren't brought over for
their ability to pollinate plants but
rather for their honey honeybees we see
in the u.s. like berry B Benson all just
started as agricultural animals like
cows probably more accurately like
chickens chickens are used to produce
eggs bees are used to produce honey it
actually took another 200 years before
honeybees were brought over to
California during the gold rush in 1853
and of
course in all of that time it's not like
the North American continent was like
some desolate desert plant life was
thriving in the Americas for thousands
of years before European settlers showed
up with their fancy beehives so how is
that possible is everything we've been
told about honeybees being an essential
part of the ecosystem and a vital part
of the reproductive lifecycle of flowers
wrong well yeah and no but yeah you see
pollinators are absolutely vital 75% of
all crops require pollination however
the idea that honeybees are a critical
part of that process in the u.s. is a
complete and utter myth first these
black and yellow striped honeybees
aren't the only type of bee out there
there are more than 20,000 species of
bees yeah 20,000 the black and yellow
stripe be kind known formerly as the
apis mellifera this formerly is the
Western honeybee is just one of them for
example take Agra post him on a genus of
bee that sounds more like a rejected
Digimon than an insect critical for
sustained plant life on earth digivolve
into these insects do make honey and
they look nothing like Barry be Benson
or the bees that we're all familiar with
but these little green guys are bees
nonetheless they're known as sweat bees
unlike honey bees which get their
nutrients by making honey from the
nectar of flowers these feed from the
sweat of mammals and yeah when I say
mammals that includes humans so if
you've ever found yourself on a hot day
swatting at one of these green gray
little bugs that seems to enjoy landing
on your neck it might not be a flyer
wasps but a sweat thirsty be trying to
get a taste of that salty secretion let
me lick your neck so yeah if you're
starting to feel like you've been lied
to your whole life about bees well you
kind of have been let's just rip that
band-aid off entirely right now bees
aren't just yellow and black only a very
few species actually make honey most
don't do that twerk dance that we've
been taught that they do for most bees
stinging does not mean death if they
even sting at all and those twenty
thousand species of bees aren't the only
pollinators out there pollen wasps ants
butterflies moths even some species of
beetle can get the job done too top
story a tri-county bee Barry Benson is
saying he intends to sue the human race
for stealing our
so if the world's honey economy were
thrown into turmoil by a lawsuit set in
motion by a talking honeybee you somehow
figured out how to work the American
legal system no problem
there'd actually be plenty of other
non-dancing equally hard-working bees
out there to pick up the slack or at
least there would have been if it wasn't
for Barry B Benson in the first place
that's right
Barry and the rest of the Western
honeybees are murderers but you don't
see anyone putting them on trial at
least until today and you had better
believe that this insect uprising needs
to be squashed what I mean is that there
are conservationists out there who
believe that the environment would be
better off without honeybees remember
how I said honey bees are an invasive
species brought in by the colonists well
according to dr. Jonas Gelman of the
University of Cambridge honey bee hives
harm the environment by crowding out all
the other local pollinators quote
there's increasing evidence that
unnaturally high densities of honeybees
associated with beekeeping can
exasperate declines in wild pollinators
besides competing with wild species for
resources honeybees are linked to the
spread of diseases to wild pollinators
via shared flowers an effect that's
likely amplified by trade width and
movement of honeybees end quote this
isn't just some random guy ranting on
his blog on the internet this was
published in Nature Nature the
scientifically reputable magazine
not.you know nature hasn't published in
the woods it's not like this guy was
pulling a primitive technology and
cueing his article into the side of a
tree this shall be my legacy anyway his
conclusions aren't all that surprising
anytime you introduce a new species to
an environment or often than not it's
gonna have negative consequences on the
local species because the invader
doesn't have any natural predators and
may be better suited to survive the new
climate actually go much more in depth
in this episode covering the invasive
species of the Pokemon verse over on
game theory so sting that I icon after
the episode - check it out but when it
comes to western honeybees the data is
there in another nature article
published by first the author's track
the global decline of bumblebees which
again to be clear are different from
Western honeybees they also don't make
honey
but bumblebees are
on the decline and it's the honeybee
diseases spilling over into their
populations that are causing it won't
again wild pollinators such as
bumblebees are in global decline when
cause of which may be a pathogen
spillover from managed pollinators like
honeybees the prevalence of deformed
wing virus and the exotic parasite knows
MLAT name in honey bees and bumblebees
is linked as honey bees have higher
deformed wing virus prevalence and
sympatric bumble bees and honey bees are
infected by the same dwv strains apis
remember that's Latin name for Western
honeybees is the likely source of at
least one major emerging infectious
disease in wild pollinators end quote
and they're not the only ones to
conclude this another study again
looking at the impact honeybees are
having on bumble bee populations
concluded the following given the
available evidence it's likely the
pathogen spillover from commercial bees
is contributing to the ongoing decline
of wild bumble bees in North America and
that's only one of the ways the
honeybees are actually killing off their
fellow pollinators when you look at
insects honeybees are unique because
they actually remove nectar from flowers
in order to make their honey while other
insects are able to pollinate flowers
without stealing the nectar well that
might not seem like that big of a deal
this paper by Diane Thompson at the
University of California Santa Cruz
found that the Western honeybees
strategy of creating nectar scarcity for
other species insures that the
competition produced fewer offspring
what a final time these results provide
evidence that apis competitively
suppress a native social be known to be
an important pollinator with the
potential for cascading effects on
native plant communities these have
never been afraid to change the world
yeah change it for the worse berry
sit your bumble butt down Seinfeld I'm
not done with you because if that wasn't
enough honey bees have one final secret
advantage in all of this they live in
protected communities unlike other
pollinators who have to fend for
themselves in the wild honey bees
because they're agricultural animals are
protected by their farmers thus giving
them a survival advantage it's a whole
heck of a lot easier for an insect
species to survive when it gets to live
in a safe little box on a farm berry
seems to think that honeybees are an
important part of the environment but
not
could be further from the truth when it
comes to ecological problems Barry isn't
part of the solution he's part of the
problem in a way the conclusion of the
b-movie is actually right about one
thing
humans and honeybees do share a critical
symbiotic relationship without human
demand for honey honeybee populations
would collapse and fall into disrepair
as mother nature exacting a revenge on
the invasive species that for so many
years has kept the native insect
populations at bay Barry be Benson
throughout the movie likes to pretend
that honeybees are the victim that they
exist under the oppressive thumb of the
evil human farmers but as this one has
come true for you exploiting tiny
helpless bees but Barry you and all
those other Western honeybees we see
throughout this movie are the real
problem the real victims here are the
native insect species whose territory
you've encroached on who you've deprived
of nectar and who you've out competed
thanks in large part to humanity's
protection in the courtroom Barry raises
a chant of really these bees free the
bees indeed free the 19900 99 other bee
species that the imperialist Western
honeybees have been keeping down for
hundreds of years
maybe then nature can exist the way it
was originally meant to but hey that's
just a theory a film Theory cut won't
you be a friend and join the loyal
theorists click that subscribe button
and while you're clicking things make
sure you click that box to the right to
find out more about invasive species and
how cute animals across the world are
dying
that's that game theory episode I
mentioned earlier now if you'll excuse
me it's time for me to buzz off I don't
know I got nothing here at least until
next week I'll see you then